You know, we all have, we all have that flaky friend.
You have that flaky friend
who claims they're gonna come to the party,
and then they just never come to the party?
Oh my God
Wait, raise of hands,
who does have that flaky friend?
Oh.
(audience laughing)
God, raise of hands,
are you at times that flaky friend?
Yeah, okay.
Only the people I'm not that close with,
and I try, and then I don't make it.
So we've all been there, no judgements,
but I do know those people who like,
every time you send an invite,
you're like, they're never showing.
They're, they say, but they're not gonna show up.
Yeah.
Well, now, Stylist reports,
there's another type of friend to watch out for,
the can't say for long friend.
Do you know them?
(audience laughing)
The can't say for long friend
is that friend who's who does show up,
but they sit down to dinner
and immediately start talking about
where they have to go next.
And they say they can only stay for like a drink or an hour,
and then they just have to go.
Some say, it's rough being friends with these people
because after a while it feels like there's like,
they're rejecting you.
I think I'm this friend.
(audience laughing)
Because I do find myself saying,
whenever people say like, oh do you wanna go to dinner?
I'm like, it's gotta be like 5:45 or six,
or I'm like out.
No, that, I think that's exempt from this category.
'Cause I'm like that too, early bird special.
I now have two kids, a full-time job,
and I'm really tired, and I gotta get to bed early.
But I have met people who tell me
that they've gotta go when they get there.
And I agree with this article,
it does feel like a mini rejection.
Does it really?
'Cause this is how I see it.
Okay, I've gotta train to take home.
I gotta work in the morning.
So no, I can't sit with you at dinner till 10,
but I can pop by for a drink,
and then bye-bye!
I think there's actually, I'm not rejecting you.
I'm trying to do what I can to meet you in the middle.
All right, show of hands,
how many people think it's makes you feel
a little cagey and weird when someone says they gotta go
right when they start the event?
Show of hands, who thinks this is a prudent way to live,
you can get more done?
(audience laughing)
I'm good with it.
Well, it will looks like there's something for everybody.
Yeah, we found her a happy little middle, as you call it.
A pretty little middle.
That's it, yeah.
My favorite.
I wanna live there.
All right, finally, some good news
if you love a good cruise.
Oh my gosh, you know how much I love going on a cruise?
I do too.
And like I want the cruise industry to be thriving,
and they've been hit so hard with the pandemic.
But I was so excited to bring this story to the news desk
because it turns out that CNN reports,
the CDC has fully lifted its COVID advisory on cruises.
That's right, baby!
(audience applauding)
The cruise industry is back, baby!
Yes, please!
I love it.
Do you wanna know one thing I really love about cruises?
Besides the fact that it's a literally a floating buffet,
which is everything I want, what?
Well, it's great for families.
It's great for singles.
There's theme cruises.
So like if you're a Turner classics movie,
or you wanna do the Love Boat theme,
or you wanna like do a booze cruise to Mexico,
like they've got it all.
You can go to Scandinavia.
I think a lot of people get intimidated with planning.
Where do I go?
How do I stay?
How do I build the itinerary?
Can I afford this?
It's jarring to travel.
And I feel like they just button everything up.
You get it on, you get off, you see, you look,
we've got your back, we take care of all of that.
And every morning you wake up and open the windows,
like where am I now?
It's so fun.
(audience laughing)
This is so awesome.
Well to celebrate, we've got something really special.
Nothing says fancy cruise like finding a towel
in the swan shape right in your room.
And today-
Yes.
We're gonna make them
because a TikToker named the Folding Lady,
who totally is going viral right now,
just revealed how to do it step by step.
Okay.
Okay, let's try it.
Some people are intimidated by travel.
I'm intimidated by trying to make a towel swan.
I didn't even know this was a thing
until I went on a cruise,
and I walked in the room, and I was like, what is that?
There's a towel swan on my bed.
Okay, so I was watching her.
Okay, do you think you know how to do it
'cause I'm scared right now?
I'm like 100% sure I don't know how to make it.
I just watched her do it.
And see, she pitches the corner,
and then it's a, look, it's like a tight roll, like-
Wait from the corner?
Corner.
Oh, okay.
You see what I'm doing?
Just you gotta hold the middle, I think,
and then just roll tight this way.
Okay, so like when you get to the midpoint,
start rolling the other side.
I think so.
And then look!
Stay!
(audience cheering)
Now what do I do?
You get all the way to twist it all the way in.
My swan looks like it is so drunk.
Just look.
(audience laughing)
(Ross groans)
Wait, okay.
Now I start-
Now you lift it up,
and it's supposed to be tight enough that it sort of stays,
but I don't think ours is.
(audience laughs)
But you kind of get the idea, right?
Nope.
(audience cheering)
You've heard of Swan Lake?
Well, this is Swan like.
(audience laughing)
What does mine look like?
Can I see a shot of it?
Oh, you know, actually-
It's not terrible.
It looks more like a snake.
Yeah.
That's like gonna hiss at you,
but I have surprised myself.
What's yours look like?
Well, mine looks pretty good.
And I think-
Yours,
I'm not trying to be rude, Rossy,
but I think mine's looks more like a swan than yours.
(audience laughing)
Dear, it's time to get your eyes checked,
all right?
But mine looks like a duck.
Oh my God, I'm holding the wrong one!
I'm looking at yours.
(audience laughing)
I'm holding-
You were looking at mine thinking it was yours?
No, this is me.
That's you.
Oh my God!
I was like, mine's so much better than yours, Rossy.
Oh my God, I'm having the moment like in a workout class
when you're in the mirror and you're like,
damn, I look good,
and you're like, that's not me, that's her.
(audience laughing)
Shoot!
Okay, mine sucks.
Yours is amazing.
I understand now.
I did have my eyes checked, Rossy,
and yours is better.
Well good for you.
Oh my gosh.
Yours wasn't all it was quacked up to be.
(audience laughing)
(upbeat music)